hi I'm Timmy the trashcan and I love
trash
[Music]
they all taste so good instead of
throwing your trash on the floor won't
you please give it to me thank you for
considering your fellow patrons hey
everybody welcome to the Tim Dylan show
back in the old studio the great gas
digital thanks to lose Gomez and Ralph
Sutton back here Rogen did a podcast
from the studio so I said you know what
I'm gonna [__] come in here and give
him a real treat give him a real treat
yeah drogon lang now you have Tim Dylan
with Shane Gillis very funny guy we love
them you know them SNL
they're not using you a lot this season
they will you'll start
they haven't written yet they have
written ya sketches that got caught you
think and I know you can't really say
any of this [__] but like is could you
go on there and do like a bit yeah is
yeah I think that I doubt it though yeah
I [__] uh no yeah you know what I
mean like a little like a desk piece ah
damn you didn't happen to boo me and be
like something fun uh yeah that's the
thing I don't think it would be that fun
yeah I think it would be fun right
personally yeah I think cuz I walked
past last week I walked past the [__]
the line people sleep outside I always
look at those people I go wasn't wrong
with you so see these guys so much to do
I walk past them that night and like
they all you know it's all these like
weirdos with like a Saturday Night Live
snow hat like in a sleeping bag looking
up from the street and I walked by and
they were like no they recognize you and
they all of course me look-ins knitted
SNL scarves and [__] it was a sick
people gonna show like that and with all
due respect everyone works there because
there's there's one or two people on
there that are funny I always look at
the show like that and I go how does it
have fans that are like the
the fervor of the fandom I get watching
it I get being like hey this is on its
sketch comedy and I think a lot of the
fans of that show are casual fans of
like this is the thing that's on
Saturday night and listen it's a his
store it's an important show in in
throughout history and it's had some
really amazingly funny stuff happen but
like in its current incarnation it's
interesting that there are people
sleeping on the street yeah dude I'm
amazed that people are sleeping on the
street to see anything yeah yeah I mean
the one thing that would make sense to
me is sleeping on the street if like
[__] Taylor Swift was there sure you
were about you were like her in a real
young I got it intimate but no they were
just s an elfin and I walked best and
this group of ladies they were all all
ladies group of ladies we're staying
there and they're like oh [__] like a
couple more excited in the morning was
just like gross and gave me the finger
really and I looked back and I was like
ah you don't mean that come on can you
imagine being that let me tell you right
now if I saw bin Laden and let's say I
buy the idea that he killed few thousand
people maybe they'd maybe then what do I
know what do I know
what do I know if I saw bin lot like my
friend's parents were incinerated if I
saw bin Laden in a restaurant I would be
like that's bin Laden yeah you know it's
cliquey idea that people are that angry
at you yeah yeah what's he about it's
like if I saw a [__] oj i'd be like
hi love I do see oj I don't know he'll
see him but III I know where he hangs
I'd love oj I've said he's the only
motivational speaker that anyone should
follow because he's on a comeback he's
lived a full life you know what I mean
like OJ Simpson has really people that
hard on it all no you haven't
Heisman have you Heisman caught
someone's [__] head off he capitated
his wife and and her [__] boy got away
with it got away we walked went back to
jail somehow [__] himself that way
you know yeah
he is a guy and I eat what he look he's
the healthiest person on Twitter most
well-adjusted he gives advice he's
golfing he's like watch the drive like I
always watch his videos he looks good
for his age
he seems happy oh yeah I mean he's true
you laugh at the hate now cuz I know
there was a time when you're obviously
like you're in it and you can't laugh at
it as much I suppose I was laughs you're
kind of laughing at me well are you
getting with their death threats they're
not real no they're not real right
they're not real so I knew that I was
never worried about death threats except
at night like before you go to sleep
then it's like then you start to walk
that [__] door yeah but uh no death
threats I didn't give a [__] about most
of them were pretty funny like if
someone would DM me just like you
[__] fat racist pig I love it I'd
have to like I'd be walking around and
read that itself oh yeah that's so funny
yeah a lot of it was really funny and
then even today they did a [__] story
Judd Apatow talked about me
and well they asked him about me and he
write it truthfully he like responded
really nicely okay like a measured
response yeah where he was like I don't
know him so people said he was doing a
character I don't know whatever but the
[__] title the articles like SNL cast
member fired for saying Judd Apatow was
gayer than Isis and it's still not
laughs like see that Lana headline is
still funny how do you not laugh at that
I don't know how you don't know for that
I guess sir I guess Chet Apatow I guess
I get how he doesn't [__] really
laugh I don't know if I the money the
Judd did and somebody said you care that
I said I would go like whoo yeah yeah
yeah think of what people deal with and
maybe he did sure how I mean yeah I was
like yeah who gives a [__] who is that I
just it's interesting that people cuz
it's interesting that anyone's like I
get the Twitter mob but anyone actually
being mad like seeing on the street me
like grabs yeah that's hilarious I when
I looked back at her and I was like ah
you don't mean that
like everyone I laughed and she smiled
it's a fun thing publicly shaming it's a
fun public shaming
is it weird have you seen any comics you
don't have to name their names and
you're certainly welcome to have you
seen any comics that threw you under the
bus then it's awkward that you're near
yeah yeah yeah for sure right
yeah there's Laurie Kilmartin
yes she I do threw me under the bus a
little Laurie just one [__] yeah she did
yes she did a show with me the stand
came up after it was like my bed I
didn't know she was like I didn't know
you were actually worried is is funny
and nice but like she sets out of
practice at mean big J and we were
discussing the net and like Laurie was
like oh did you guys not like it I'm
like oh you don't know any like we've
never met clearly like but no she was
actually cool about it she was one
that's good but she did it you know
privately yeah well that's what a lot of
[__] on me on Twitter and then private a
lot of people the videos that I make a
lot of people will actually message me
and go there so that is so funny but
they will never eat wheat [__] because
still now cuz I we do some wild [__] and
they'll never retweet it yeah they just
go yeah it's funny well that's how it's
always been behind ya my god when I went
out to LA yeah and went on all these
[__] general meetings right go in
there and be like I think Louie is the
[__] best right every agent and
[__] oh yeah was really yeah he is
yeah but we can't you know yeah yeah
every one of them so behind closed doors
everybody knows what's funny well that's
what it is it's like I think a lot of
people that make a lot of big money they
got it they got I I realize that I value
freedom over money
yeah so like I want to be able to say
what I want to say and if people are
gonna not like it that's okay but I
don't know if there's enough money I'd
literally realize this and I'm like I
don't know if there's enough money to
get me to shut up
it's just I'm hard it's too hard just
from not personally and by the way that
makes me an idiot that doesn't make me
I'm not feel like I'm a revolutionary
I'm too stupid like I don't get cuz
there should be enough money to make me
shut up there should be but I just don't
know how to do I wouldn't know how to do
it yeah it's hard yeah it's definitely
hard and that's what you and a lot of
people don't realize you could have went
out and did a Mia culpa and when I was
there
never been an excuse to die die on the
shame to myself I hate but you didn't do
it no I was I was asked to do this you
were asked to do it and yeah I couldn't
not because I was I was like [__]
sorry about some things like right I
don't want to [__] hurt anybody's
feel I wouldn't want those words written
yeah like it's I know I [__] said it
yeah was behind it I mean anybody hurt a
lot of people I mean that's what these
Hong Kong protests are about yeah
they're folks about your podcast it is
nothing to do with the extradition
treaty that's a cover
it's a hurt a lot of people hurt a lot
of people yeah I yeah I don't I mean
even saying that I feel [__] corny I
don't even know if I really heard I
think anything that we say listen this
is what people don't understand about
comedy and I and and and it's because
they're not funny or they're they don't
understand like the way that funny works
you cannot control how anyone takes a
joke like I text people and I go are
they gonna get what I'm doing yeah no
they're not you know like I'll text
somebody and I'll be like I don't even
does this person hate me now yeah I'm
texting a YouTube kid I'm kind of
friends with friendly would yeah and I
text him a jokes and it like I don't
know if he gets it
yeah I'd I doubt it but you you did you
think to yourself if I if I apologize I
will for the rest of my life be owned
yes yeah for sure I was like well also
if I apologize for this and say like
this was inexcusable
they're gonna find [__] wait what
about this way he works whatever yeah oh
well that was also unexcusable that was
also an excusable and then when I'm done
apologizing like that what can I do
I could imagine calm you know mr. Dylan
did you make a joke about pedophilia yes
did you dress up as a temple from a
pedophile island yes yes yeah I do
apologize for that but what I always say
about your situation I'm like Shane
Gillis got fired so that none of us can
get hired and I appreciate their my
agent called me the day it happened with
you and went
well um we can kiss s it out goodbye I
was like I didn't even know we were in
contention he's like we weren't but just
in case you ever thought that that's no
[__] no I was in contention yeah but
what's great about what I love about
your thing is like I there's a part of
comedy and the good part of it is like
sports right like it's like there's
there's definite winners and losers and
like when you when you watch somebody on
stage crush you're like they're [__]
winning they might not have the comedy
you like they might but as long as
they're doing their own [__] or whatever
it's like it's a win it could be an ugly
win it might not be all when you agree
with it to win and you people don't
understand about that process that
audition process
it's a [__] hard process it gets in a
lot of people's heads and to make it
through that and to get the [__] job
says something and there's a lot of
people that were probably angry at you
know number one because they knew that
they could not make it to that process
yeah they didn't even get selected for
the process but it's it's like what can
you talk about what the process is yeah
I can talk about my process yeah I yeah
I went they saw me at jfl answer fest
would call me central and they're like
we want you to come in and test so then
you go in and you [__] audition on
the main stage and what is that what is
that audition usually you have to do
like characters and impressions and
right but I think now they've loosened
it to where like if you're a stand-up
you can just do stand-up okay so I just
did five minutes a stand and you're
doing it to who table of writers in that
whole [__] empty studio and the whole
big eyes - now studios - table around
Michaels Lorne yeah and that's the first
time I ever [__] saw him yeah she's a
walking maker and right yeah and when
you get there you don't you wait in the
green rooms I like the the [__] cast
members rooms right so you're just in
there waiting right for like two three
hours while every single person there
auditioning goes through and that that's
what sketchy people that get some people
catching your head cuz this is the job
intentional that's why they do it right
if it gets your heads right cuz it's a
live show they put it on Saturday night
it's live yeah so if you can't handle
pressure or if you buckle
you can't be on the team and I was
sitting there thinking like there's zero
[__] chance I get this so I literally
I was like okay fine
didn't give a [__] right sitting in
there best attitude to have
dipping she own tobacco in the back pack
in a lift
yeah I had a lip in I was just sitting
there and then when they when they
brought me in though that's when it
really [__] hit like yeah because you
they bring you to a separate green room
where you sit while the other person
before you is on and that guy you got
five minutes and it's like oh [__] [__]
and it's not like people are killing
because there's just a you can't even
see anybody else right see the room
until you walk in right I didn't even
see the stage until I walked onto the
stage right so then you walk out in
front of everybody and it's this big
empty room with two cameras all right
and they give you the [__] camera guy
goes 3 2 you say your name and go right
and then you just get the [__] off the
stage after you did this at were you
like this is good after I did the set
well I had heard you're not like people
don't laugh right but they left the
whole time that so I was a good sign
yeah I think that's good yeah and then
when I you know I got the callback and I
was like [__] I got it and was it what
was the callback callback was just to
come in and meet all the writers and
[__] and producers crazy it was crazy
and everyone cool everybody was great it
was [__] awesome it was genuinely an
awesome experience it all worked out and
that's why you have trips because yeah
but that's that's a wild process and
I've heard a few people have gone
through that and I know some people have
not had the editions they've wanted to
have and some people have had good
auditions and it's just still for
whatever reason did it work
yeah well also the thing is is like I
mean don't get me wrong Santa live is
[__] awesome
of course like as soon as I got it I was
like [__] yes yeah but that was never on
the agenda like I was just crying I knew
I did this right so I knew I was never
gonna be [__] mainstream like that
yeah I would have to I just wanted to do
stand-up yeah it's interesting that we
you know I feel like a few years ago
none of that was a consideration because
nobody was doing like we we were all
kind of just waiting for people to give
us a job
yeah you know write us a check and now
now that's a little different I don't I
don't know I it sucks that everything is
this [__] fractured yeah cuz I look
at people that are talented that I think
are very funny but then I'm like because
I do this and I'm in this camp yeah and
they're in that other camp and I'm like
could we ever collaborate or work
together because you're like over there
and you think I'm like you know in this
camp of all right the odd casters which
is completely insane and ridiculous and
I think all of them like those guys are
social justice warriors but that's also
insane it's like everybody's kind of
afraid of each other which is yeah my
sucks I feel like they bully us you know
yes if I see them in public I'm like
[__] they're gonna you know yeah some of
these comics with complete impunity
could walk up to me at a comedy club be
like you pieces [__] right everybody
would be like yeah that's yeah man
you're allowed to say that to you yeah
or she's allowed to say that to you it's
like okay
have you had an incidents like that
where people somebody's been hostile
openly uh no right now it's mostly
passive-aggressive it's like as they
saying like hip-hop it's like it's on
wax yeah it's not real it's not really
real same thing with Twitter if you just
delete Twitter all this [__] all this
[__] talk goes away yeah it's hard
though it's hard to stop looking dog
yeah I tried not to read YouTube
comments or reddit comments or any of
that stuff but you kind of yeah kind of
get back into that fray yeah did you
have any friends in your hometown that
we're happy cuz I would have friend like
my friend like yeah oh [__] yeah like I
would most of my friends would be
happier than I was in and embroiled in a
national scandal than me getting a job
cuz I'm from Long Island so like that's
now they'd be like one of our national
scandal they'd be like [__] yeah yo you
see Carrie like that you know yeah
definitely had that yeah definitely had
yeah I mean it [__] comic
like that right there's definitely like
there's a level of like people who all
in this network we're like that
potentially and I have it too so I'm not
[__] on it yeah or at least I had it
hopefully I lost a little but where I
kind of [__] if you're not succeeding
yeah when someone else succeeds you like
well then when they get [__] brought
down you're yeah what a lot of people
believe it's a shitty thing but a lot of
people are like you know like a lot of
people believe that the path we've all
taken is the path and nobody none of us
will have mainstream success and then
when somebody does we're like oh [__]
and then when somebody is yanked away
we're like Siri and it's you know I get
it it's not even you honey if it
happened to anybody else I would
definitely be laughing also I was
laughing at it happen to me it was kind
of funny the whole time it was one of
those things I listened but one of the
reasons I was going so hard on Twitter
against a lot of this [__] is like I I
tend to view it all as like all of these
people tweet about mental health every
day and how important is self-care and
then they're trying to tweet you out of
a window they're trying to tweet you to
kill yourself and it to me like the
hypocrisy is so deep and thick as a
comic I look at it and I'm like this is
wild you guys are the tolerant ones all
those comics that are exactly that are
these super tolerant like woke [__]
nice all these things right they're the
meanest [__] people I know
yeah like ehrenburg's the man yeah guy
he's and then you'll run into like a
[__] gay writer from show that's just
a [__]
then our angry yeah well the thing that
happened with the gay comedy scene and I
don't know when it happened and I'm not
a huge part I'm not at all a huge part
of it though I always forget I'm no part
of the gay comedy scene and it's not a
just have no interest in me I don't have
a huge interest in them but it's an
insular scene it's it's spun off from
the alts and I will say this in the
queer comedy scene in New York there's a
little bit of talent whereas in the
alternative comedy scene there's no
talent so it's a much better it's al its
but there's
there's something going on now where
people see that the route to success is
to to brand themselves as somebody with
the right opinions and and and the right
opinions on your thing we're like that
what you do is hate speech or what we do
leaving us gangs like these guys are
hate speech skank fester charlottesville
by the way if they'd ever been near a
skank fast they would they would know
that that's absurd but none of them have
because they're in this little scene and
they don't go out and they don't know
anybody and they don't know us and to me
as a gay person it was never interesting
to me to just do a little scene of
people in the East Village and entertain
each other and entertain our friends I
didn't want to do that I wanted to
entertain as many people as I could
because I'm a comic that's my job but I
think the way that they show they look
at me and they're like oh this is a guy
with the wrong opinions yeah like Tim
gonna be like Ben Carson yeah like a Ben
Carson what the hell's he doing on that
side yeah I think but they all still
respect me that I'm funny and I can do
well in the rooms they working because I
work those run so there's no argument
they can't say that I'm not funnier that
I can't do well in Brooklyn so I can do
well in all that [__] but I just I'm a
little I think they look at me and
they're like well we don't really know
where he stands or we don't like where
he stands or whatever but again some of
the message me privately but what they
don't realize is that the woke snake
just eats itself totally it'll eat
itself and what I like gay guys used to
pride themselves in being like tough
cynical mean catty vicious and then now
they're moralists in this new and drag
queens are more or less and it's boring
it's boring the morality please is
boring that's why your aunt Sheryl is
not a comedian you know it's like cuz
you know she's like Jesus Saves you like
that's nice thank you keep baking that's
fine but nobody's gonna pay money to see
when a nightclub Cheryl like so to me
seeing that seeing
I mean drag queens you when you talk
about politically incorrect [__] they
used to say the most [__] up [__] yeah
some of it was brutal
brutally funny so insanely I'm busy and
now it's like they're afraid to say
anything and I say who wants a
politically correct drag queen who wants
a 6-4-3 guy dressed up in a dress with a
crazy wig who's like the most important
thing to vote Democrat vote for
Elizabeth Warren it's like what the [__]
is going on party line make fun of that
Asian guy and be like he's got a little
dick like that's what I would do that
what you wouldn't do it but if I saw
drag queen not making Rick I want race
humor I want I know brow she's like
humor from a drag queen I want lowbrow
not even good not even particularly good
but just funny like funny like what the
[__] am I even hearing humor from a drag
queen I don't want like some moral
crusade
it would be insane like if then that was
a drag queen that would have been insane
that special for her to walk out yeah
and you know i you know but i think
it'll it swings one way it swings the
other way and some of those people are
talented and whatever but it is kind of
funny that you know it is what it is
it's some of those guys you know I'm
messaging privately and they'll message
me back they'll be like oh you're very
funny you know one of them was like I
really enjoy your work or whatever and
then I'll be like oh cool and but again
there would be no public acknowledgement
of that ever yeah let me know public you
know Lewis is a sweet guy people don't
realize that Lou's Gomez is actually a
good person he's a good father yeah he's
like a good dude I know a lot of woke
people who've done nothing for their
kids Louis is like a good dude and I
think that that like [__] people
don't understand that either yeah you
know yep well he is shitty though to
know was very shitty shitty he's shitty
and good I love you know he's good man
yeah but he's not a bad guy these people
think he's a hateful bad guy yeah but
now he's doing that [__] thing with
the glasses and the muscle he looks like
hunter his Thompson if he didn't read or
write yeah it makes no sense yeah have a
look you know
yeah but if you have any branded
right-wing don't have a particularly he
just leans in I mean say Brandon is a
furry he'll walk around dressed like a
rabbit you know what I mean like it just
leans in if they were like Lewis is a
furry he'd be like what up dog is just
you know dog ears flopping around I mean
he would he would lean into it folks
many of you in my audience have sexual
problems you know you cannot perform
anxiety depression many of you morbidly
obese your penises don't work you're
sick you have anger issues your
testosterone level is low you have
diseases cancer is ravaging different
parts of your body you have drug and
alcohol dependence pills powders booze
whatever it is you have sports injuries
that have never healed you don't have
health insurance you don't go to the
doctor your mind is a conspiracy addled
thing that you filled with sugar and
drugs for your entire life booze and
sugar and food you've spent all of your
life at a drive-thru just cramming salt
and fat down your throat to so you could
feel something anything
your lot you just you're in a coma your
entire life is just driving around
listening to other people and every now
and then you get a chance you get a fat
woman in sandals that's hammered walking
out of a lily Flanagan's it wants to
[__] and this is it you get to take her
back to your basement and this is the
night that mom's had a few pills so
she's asleep and she won't hear you but
you can't get hard when it matters and
it haunts you forever and it only makes
you drink and eat more and punch more
things that you can't afford to fix so
instead of that instead of having that
horrible experience that only sends you
further down a spiral of hatred and
despair how about blue Chu okay blue qu
can increase your performance you get
that extra confidence inbred blue troop
brings you the first chewable the same
FDA improved ingredients as Viagra and
Cialis so you know they work you can
take them any time day or night even on
a full stomach sometimes I wake up take
a blue to just get hard look at it and
go right back to bed you don't even need
a partner this isn't just for guys who
can't perform its for any guy who wants
to function extra you want to [__] more
rounds go harder land the girl that has
the Toyota Corolla or whatever you think
you whatever
segments of society you're [__]
yourself into you you got to come
prepared okay you want around two and
three that's blue true it's prescribed
online it's shipped straight to your
door in the discrete package so no
in-person doctor visit no waiting in the
pharmacy bumping into people that are
doing better than you with a family with
kids with a real job and you're standing
there disgusting telling them about your
cbdu business none of that none of that
standing there with your soft dick in
your hand and you're no [__]
accomplishment you get to sit right in
your house they deliver it in discreet
packaging right to your door okay maybe
a post mate notices it as she hands you
your [__] meat loaf from Friday's or
whatever you're eating here Tennessee
whiskey chicken wings you monster
they're made in the USA also they're
also made in the USA
none of these Pakistani dick pills not
for you you believe in this goddamn
country you got an American flag as your
profile picture and you've never served
in the military but you've watched a lot
of military movies and you support
people to do and that's almost more
important you're fighting the war where
it matters on Facebook and Twitter
you've been banned three times on
Facebook for telling the truth and now
you're out of facebook jail you leaked
Nancy Pelosi's address they shut down
the Donald you got nowhere to write
anymore listen you need a little blue
chill you hate Acacio Cortes but you
still beat off to it this is what I'm
talking it's a large section of my
people right now we've got a special
deal for our listeners visit blue jicama
get your first order free when using the
promo code t I am even you [__] could
spell that T I am just pay five dollars
shipping free
dick pills there's no reason at the
bottom if you like the show and you want
to [__] someone twice in a row buy it do
you understand what I'm saying
promo code t IM that's blue2 dot-com
blue2 com promote code Tim to try it
free thank you are you Matt and Shane
Seger podcast you still do that all the
time yeah is that if he's still in
Philly he's good he's in Philly he's
having a kid and everything yeah yeah
yeah what how often still he's two hours
away yeah says it yeah
the best it's easy to drop down helium
is one of the best clubs ever it is yeah
I love that
did I work with you there no we did
Magoo bees we didn't Magoo bees
I was with McKeever at helium he's a
monster he's a monster ma'am John
McKeever he was a monster John McKeever
was great he featured and and then Chris
O'Connor Chris O'Connor hosted those are
my guys
and we had a lot of fun and then I was
with Chris in meet Chris O'Connor the
crystal Connors Ark is that crazy he's
like a guy it looks super normal in his
name he's a nightmare which was like
well I he's like my best friend I love
him but he's not as great for ya I'm
gonna expose him here go ahead but he me
and him walked into a prison we walked
to know a maximum-security prison in
North Carolina like he's like I threw it
out as a joke I'm like dude we should
walk in his prison he's in and and offer
to do a comedy show there I want to see
and Chris is like dude yes
and I'm like no problem what are we and
we walk into the prison and offered to
do like a comedy show for the inmates
because we wanted to see the prison
that's how insane O'Connor is that type
of guy like he's a guy he walks around
like a Patagonia jacket yeah North Face
thing he's like clean-cut he's from
Connecticut but then just inside he's
just unhinged right just totally yeah
he's out of his mind he's wild
this is that wild is yeah this is a
story he's told before so I don't feel
bad Tommy yeah me and him did healing
him Indianapolis yeah while I was asleep
I came home late yeah in the hotel room
meeting him shared a hotel room I was
passed out drunk he got a hooker to come
in crane 6:00 in the morning when I got
in he woke up I was like I'll [__] I
should get a [__] called a hooker a
[__] got a [__] in the bathroom
while I was asleep
and she lit like that's the type of but
that's it in the same but it was a move
and the hooker was afraid of me like she
walked in was like you mentioned she
like a hooker walking in a room doesn't
want to see you or me on and out they
weren't prepared
don't want to walk in and just see just
some guy being like oh hello where's the
party yeah he tried to hide it you tried
to hide it from me but
I went to the bathroom in the morning
the lotion was all over the counter
Connor what are you doing paying for a
[__] uh in Indiana great point
200 maybe 200 now 200 max - just get her
over there god yeah
sorry Chris Chris O'Connor my suckers
he's a good guy yeah
got a hundred thousand people listen to
this you know go follow Chris tell them
that there's nothing wrong that he likes
prostitutes did sex workers these tax
workers are great yeah and I'm pro sex
worker I live in Los Angeles the
majority of people like you look at
couples and restaurants and you're like
this is just long we got we blew out
well it started before that started with
Ari Shaffir talking a lot of [__] and
then calling me and tell me to take it
off the thing
thanks ro I remember that right yeah so
that started the bump and then the bump
just got bigger and bigger than Rogen
obviously huge me and Chris de Stefano
Yanis Papa's just did a two hour podcast
that we we don't know if we can release
because we just want wild and started in
a loving way [__] on other comics as
a joke because they have fun because
it's fun and it's like you know yeah but
and I use your example towards the end I
was like why should we censor ourselves
none of them they went after shame they
go after this and these people say I
everybody's this and Luise rapist and
none of them sent to them saying you
know but then at the end we were like
still we were like probably Chris it was
like 'hey we shouldn't yeah I've had a
bunch of those yeah they still got me
yeah that was [__] watered down [__]
why didn't ya
do you think I had somebody do you think
if there wasn't video to this it
wouldn't have somebody told me that an
interesting theory they're like if it
wasn't video it might not have been as
big yeah I don't I don't know I don't
know the whole time I was like like
leading up to it I had like I
month like a week to be like should I
[__] delete everything yeah
I didn't delete there I deleted a good
chunk of our podcast just the audio of
it just cuz I there was some [__] on
there like me [__] on comics right
like now I'm friends with right goes
from me in a basement in West Philly
just resentful yeah talking [__] on like
I was doing open mics in Philly right
and I was like oh I'm not getting this
cuz I'm a [__] straight white right
right right and then as soon as I moved
to New York I got everything immediately
right and I was like alright well maybe
I was kind of being a [__] release yeah
white thing right and yeah so I got rid
of that stuff where I was like [__]
on comics that I want you know who found
it and sent it to the shelves I told me
this though last night I could find that
out yeah he told me some kid last night
told me it was a Philly Filioque had to
be that leaked it to ya it had to be
somebody that didn't like you yeah I
forgot to ask the kid he has them yeah
he could don't you yeah it makes sense
the [__] the the same fracture that
happened here happened in Philly when I
was there where I heard all the woke
kids well now I don't know what else to
[__] describe them there was just bad
comedians but [__] not all of them are
like there are talented people that are
just insane now that and I think a lot
of our people that are like a lot of the
interesting at least like they're rich
white straight guys yeah in LA that have
been at the top of it and they're like
they're like gotta work extra hard yeah
because they're like I want to retain my
position so I got a [__] really yeah
there was one lady that literally
[__] she tweeted out that I called
her the n-word right cuz she said I
called her ass and n-word it's not true
this is great what part of the bid is
that I was like that's a really
aggressive crowd war at helium I ran
into one of her friends yeah and I was
like well what the [__] was that like a
right just lie oh yeah yeah and she was
this is how she literally responded this
is the type of people were dealing with
she was like well just cuz she wasn't
telling the truth doesn't mean she was
lying yeah I was like wow [__] does
cuz she tweeted my name out yeah it said
the n-word that's crazy man who's
[__] wild so wild the fracture and
filly happened and actually in Philly
happened like it did in most places when
Trump won right Trump won all those the
[__] harmony kind of broke and they
needed to get somebody right they felt
compelled to be like this is how we yeah
fight this power and they just would
attack like me yeah you know yeah and
yeah do you think do you think that like
your personal relationships with any of
them impacted that do you think like
when you look back we like man I maybe I
could have been nice here to some of
them the [__] three mics a week
together I'm not really nice to people
either so I'm getting drunk get on stage
and be like look there's a decent chance
I'm the only one here talented enough to
do I mean I do that every night every
night I would get up and say everyone
should quit I still do that I do that to
millionaires III would get up and say
everyone should not do this yeah because
I thought it was funny and I also
believe that every word was saying Tony
it's very funny and accurate so but yeah
so I know that there's people out there
that aren't there they hate it they
really my example if somebody else did
it like got on stage and was like you
should quit I'd laugh I'd be like yeah
that's pretty funny yeah the other thing
is like did I ignore McDonald who's a
legend tell me I did last comic standing
exactly what are you doing here it's
like five years ago he's like what are
you doing here I'm like he's like how
long you doing hominid I'm like uh four
years he's like it takes ten years to be
a comedian so I was just like and now he
like thinks I'm great or he thinks the
stuff I do is really funny so it's like
you get a gut punch from this legend
this icon yeah and you're like you're in
the thrust in a situation you're not
ready to be in and he's like so was like
if you can't take me or you would an
open mic saying well that's I that's why
yeah that's why they should quit right
they couldn't handle that right one one
guy got upset because when Trump won the
night he won the night of the election
yeah one of my favorite nights
accommodate it was wild I'll tell you
what I was after that yeah so I was at
helium's open like what yeah Tuesday
night Mike okay so we're on stage just
coming out and being like cuz every
comic was going on and crying right I
mean like this is horrible and then I
would go on yeah whoo suck my [__]
dick stinky we did it yeah like all that
[__] but uh at the comics Mike like
where he doesn't care it's just fun I
don't give a [__] don't care I don't
wanna
he shouldn't be the [__] know show
house it's like not good but for me it
was I was yeah I was sleeping on a
[__] mattress right Edie of the Auris
right I was I was you know I didn't care
who won right uh and that the comics
like I was ice I said I said [__] yeah
and I was like well we're allowed to say
it now Trump won I don't know if you
guys know this we're allowed to say fact
right clearly a [__] joke clearly a
check but couldn't be more of a joke
right people's you know some guys got
upset people got angry they were upset
after yes in the room everyone was
laughing
did the power of comics and a lot of us
buy new our own [__] of like what we
can do and I think the reality is we're
not that important like it all we're not
at all really important like at all and
like none of us were like Carlin Hicks
Pryor nobody really was listen they were
important to us too important in the art
form to the overall thing they were not
a big huge deal really
you just weren't um so I think that that
inflated sense of what comics can do but
I was in - I'm sorry just to go off of
that yeah the inflated sense the one
thing I do want to apologize now that
yeah decent audience yeah yeah didn't
mean to say I'm a comedian that pushes
boundaries that [__] was corny okay I
retract that statement yeah in the
moment it made sense if you know right I
literally I had five minutes to type
that [__] thing you're you're trying
to write a statement for the entire
world in five minute and it's yeah I
literally I had five minutes right
because I was saying no I'm not gonna
write it and then I got a phone call
that said hey [__] write something or
we have to fire you right now right so I
was a guy here's something yeah and I
didn't really apologize you should have
texted me I would have written something
I had a pretty good guy right I wish I
had that platform dear world I don't
know that's what you think
yeah that's what you're saying you know
what and I yeah there was
I mean I wish I just post my thing would
have been as a comedian
the Jews fun that would have been yeah
in hindsight yeah of course I wish I was
I was at the Chris Gethard
live show okay
sitting next to a guy dressed like
banana who was crying he was crying like
what's the term for like just non-stop
sobbing it's like Sabich wailing and I
said to him I said cheer up but I was
like your banana like yah
yeah because I'm a plantain I said well
as Trump's America banana banana
and you know rich white women of course
it's throwing themselves on the floor
and we're beating their hands oh yeah
man they'd brought me in and Ray and Ray
Caputo co-hosted to shove me for long
time they brought us and he's like
lovable heels yes I thought Hillary was
gonna win it we were gonna be like
listen who cares
she's corrupt she's a Crump but it
doesn't matter you know whatever they
brought us in is like that then when it
looked like Trump was winning and I was
on the phone my friend drew Michael
Andrew Michael was working at SNL at the
time as a writer and he was telling me
that like kate mckinnon and all those
people were like crying it was like wild
yeah and I was like well didn't they
know that this was an option like one of
the two was gonna win Yeah right like
one of them was gonna and I was on the
road for that year I knew that there was
a very good possibility it was Trump I
didn't think it was gonna be Trump but I
knew there was a possibility I yeah I
haven't cried like my grandma died today
right really that's Oh God sorry I
forgot about I don't know he was 85
interesting yeah yeah yeah well I'm
sorry by that I didn't like I did that
was a loss but right you know that's
[__] like these people a [__]
political candidate loss and they yeah
they were throwing them like you said
rolling on the floor like yeah sort of
like the Holy Spirit took over yeah does
it mean sorry throw that grandma thing
in there nothing funny though right
it's hilarious
died uh yeah this old woman died my
mom's mom it was my last grandpa she
died like her she I couldn't think of
one nice memory and I lived with her for
a little while okay but she was funny do
you think she leaked the podcast to SATs
I had she she was funny she was like an
old dignity people are mean funny lady
people wouldn't funny almost died like
for the last year but she hung on digits
torture I've had to iron a suit like
three times this yeah get ready she's
goin she still come in she's fully
clothed walking around but her while she
was dying tonight uh I was on the phone
right before he came in yeah
my mom and her siblings were around my
dying grandma and she like took her leg
and my aunt walked over and like grabbed
her head it was like oh mom and then my
grandma was like scared yeah she jumped
and then they all started laughing and
my family was dying laughing yeah while
my grandpa died she died with her kids
around her laughing that's great what a
great way to go
what a nice - the best way to go just
laughing their asses off she's choking
yeah we should conscious to know that
stuff was going on with you know I don't
think oh yeah [__] maybe that killed her
blood on your hand chef yeah what do you
think's wrong with a guy like that I
mean obviously probably I don't give him
a ton of attention because I don't want
to I mean Yanis fights of them all dad
Twitter I'll wake up yacht is fighting
with him I'm like on it have a bagel
yeah but who is a guy that just wants to
watch things burn as he's that he seems
angry the Joker dude yeah he's a jerk he
seems like a guy that's just unhappy did
he ever reach out to you was he ever
like a comment you have it you wanted no
part of that he just wanted to it's
[__] talk to him to rise I I also
think he believes he's doing a [__]
good thing right like I think he does I
don't think it's this no he probably
does I don't think it's as vindictive or
[__] up so did Muhammad Atta
yeah yeah I think he genuinely believes
like he is doing something I don't think
I mean of course there's some like
vindictive [__] underneath it all but I
think he probably thinks he's doing the
right thing yeah and you just kind of
you're like I'm a hologram
I don't care alright somebody else
yeah for sure I don't care at all about
him yeah like I don't care he's fine
yeah he's exactly who they are right so
it's impossible like it's like getting
mad at a dog for biting you right you'd
be a psycho right it is well you know
it's just what that's that guy's nature
for sure yeah it's two dudes to be a
tattle-tale I've had those I get that
it's serious when Trump wanna I get to
people were sad and because you're like
well there's but it's like it's also
like well you're living in a country
where half the people disagree and the
other half like they all like the
reality is that people disagree there
are people that think abortion is murder
I don't think that but there's people
that think that yeah there's people that
think that gay people are dangerous I
don't believe that I think that they're
wrong but there's people to believe that
I don't want those people put in
internment camps no I don't I I don't
want to lose any rights out of the gay
people should lose any rights but I
don't care what you think of me like
that's the other thing it's like I don't
really care what your opinion of me is
and I feel like a lot of this comes from
the idea that everybody has to think a
certain way and you have to control how
they think I don't care it means nothing
to me what people do it and I think
would trump one it was this affront to
this idea it's a gig you're sharing the
country with people that some of them
agree with you some of them don't many
of them don't care you know the whole
thing about everybody hates you
everybody it's like no people don't care
no yeah and here travel I travel yeah
these crowds of people you can go from
[__] Brooklyn to Rio Aska all right
whatever and and there's nobody really
doing hate speech on stage and getting a
laugh like nobody's doing that that
doesn't happen that's the other thing
that people don't understand about
comedy clubs you can't get up and start
saying wildly offensive things if
they're not very very very funny yeah
and everybody's laughing because they
know it's a joke and if they don't know
what's a joke even if they think it's
not a joke
that guy's looks like Andrew Schultz who
hasn't succeeded some God reserved
I don't know who that guy is but you
didn't put the captions underneath
cabinets that guy did not put the
captions
it is well now you just go from here
like [__] oh there's any any anybody
that you became friendly with in a
surprising way from this uh yeah there's
been a couple but like yeah as far as
moving forward it's like yeah [__]
keep doing Santa that's not like again
that's it now I'm doing the road
I got [__] that's what I was that's
what I was doing before this thing right
just started headlining yeah just
started headlining like well there are
people that didn't have your back that
you were disappointed it didn't have
your back I swear to God I didn't give a
[__] like throughout interesting most of
the time I didn't give a [__] uh I mean
it took a lot out of me it was just a
phone call after phone call after phone
with agents and managers and right and
it's a big PNC and [__] the news was
calling every news outlet in the world
was calling they all get your number
immediately that's crazy I'm out I get
your cell phone in the worst yeah get my
family's cell phone immediately uh but
yeah as far as people that didn't have
my back I don't know no I don't think
yeah there's nobody where you were like
yeah no yeah that's good
no I didn't have any grudges I don't
have any grudges against anyone that
really really spoke out against me me a
couple that I'm like what the [__] are
you doing right like what are you
[__] doing like delete you knew
personally or know people that I knew
kind of but just again I don't doesn't
matter it doesn't [__] matter like
yeah and also I get people that listened
to that clip yeah if if you read that
clip under the the headline that was
like this is racist as far away till you
hear this right it's gonna look pretty
[__] bad right but if you listen to
it or like oh maybe he's making fun of
people that would segregate Chinatown
which is so and then you also get fans
and there are also people that think it
is racist and think it's great you're
great yeah there's guys that'll [__]
yeah the only people that recognize me
are white dudes I'll be walking down the
street know why - yeah
I gotta talk about flat earth you know
now keep speaking your truth yeah some
of that's crazy sometimes I'll get
messages and I'm like God yeah you get a
lot of those most of the hate the
[__] da I was getting like [__]
hundreds of DMS every single day for the
last like month yeah just people talking
[__] yeah and everyone if you respond
with like a sad face emoji there they
immediately retract attention yeah it's
weird there's one attention like Oh
somebody ability somebody sometimes
people attack and DM I'll respond or
something a big I'm just kidding I love
you I love the show exact some and it's
like oh you just you want to just engage
with people you have some you just want
to engage yeah support for the Tim Dylan
show comes from manscaped manscape is
the best and below the belt grooming
manscape offers precision-engineered
tools for your family jewels sculpt it
down there people are in the porn now
people know your digs supposed to look
like clean your area up you know
especially maybe a lot of you aren't
there's not a lot down there anyway
make it look nice perfume it shave it
sculpted take some pride in it you know
we all know that house with a the the
lawn grew and there was an old woman
named VY that lived there and she was
kind of a witch and her son lived with
her and he had a problem which we now
know his autism but back then we just
called it being a bit off and you know
people were worried about him but he
wasn't a pedophile he eventually married
an older woman who was a biker and then
they lived together and it was [__]
weird and they didn't have kids but they
cared for vayan til if I died under kind
of weird circumstances but the grass was
disgusting and you would never go there
except on Halloween and he would open it
and give you disgusting candy and your
prawns would check it for razor blades
that lawn is what your [__] dick
looks like you got to clean your [__] up
clean it up and sculpt it people want to
suck you you just got to show them how
people who want to it's okay
people want to [__] you you just got to
clean it up shave it shave your shaft
you got hair on the shaft hair on the
balls clean it up people like a nice
hairless sack it's fun it's fun for a
nicely
manscaped is a perfect package and
includes the crop preserver and anti
chafing ball deodorant and moisturizer
you ready put deodorant on your armpits
why are you not putting deodorant on the
grossest part of your body okay speaking
of sweaty balls I'm thankful for their
crop Reviver this product along with the
crop preserver keep your balls from
sweating smelling and sticking all these
products smell good they have a manly
scent it's very attractive it'll help
set the mood the perfect package will
also come with a pair of manscape boxer
briefs
they'll keep your chunk feeling fresh
whole day this is a reality I have a man
scamper it does work it is very good you
need to use this the only other product
on the market really is like the norelco
body groom and that will cut your dick
off literally manscape takes a lot of
many of you whether you have depth
perception problems or you're never
quite sober you don't want to be going
near your dick with a razor unless
they've taken precautions to make it
safe manscaped has really done that they
know that you people are limited and
they know that their product has to make
it safe for you to go near your penis
okay they don't want you bleeding you
know nobody wants a bloody dick get 20%
off free shipping code Tim T IM at
manscape calm ma n s CA PE d calm promo
code Tim if you love the show and you
need to [__] you know sculpt the hair
down there use manscaped I'm telling you
that's the way to do it it's the right
move okay don't go buy it from somebody
else if you like the show and you need
it get it [__] done your balls will
thank you get 20% off and free shipping
with the code T IM at manscape com
that's 20% off free shipping at man
skate calm use promo code Tim clean up
your nuts and make Santa proud this year
well it's a little early for that but
whatever this is a copy they sent show
you dick off at Thanksgiving walk in say
look what I did look at this show your
[__] at Thanksgiving and make it
beautiful there's a lot of families
where somebody will show their other
members of their family their penis it's
not the greatest families to grow up and
a lot of people have residual issues but
if it's nice-looking they can't get that
mad get out of here what about your
parents what's the family
had a day huh they were they're [__]
cool with it uh I mean my MOT like my
they obviously have a sense of humor my
mom just laughed as her mom died Yeah
right
obviously they're funny yeah yeah yeah
dark funny people but my dad the only
one he got fired up and my mom they got
worried because when I got in trouble I
did I did a spot at the stand where I
made fun of it be I said it would be
funny if Trump got shot like his
assassination would be objectively a
funny right the the footage of the
assassination would be comical him grata
so I did a joke about that
and there were [__] reporters at the
show that took it out they wrote it down
or sent it to Fox News like that week
Wow so Fox News ran a [__] thing that
like I was joking that it'd be funny if
Trump got shot oh boy
or like jingles calls for assassination
oh yeah so when my parents saw that my
dad was like what the hell are you doing
yeah it's our only bridge you're burning
your last bridge here don't yell get the
Trump people go yeah yeah so that was
the one thing he was upset about
that's so funny yeah because he loved
dude he loves our president yeah he
loves 45 Trump Trump has a cult
following yeah you got he got dads I
think my dad liked him too but he does
admit it because his wife is very
liberal so I think my dad like like my
dad just texting you know like his his
wife's listener their three dogs names
Ruth for Ruth Bader Ginsburg swear to
god Fred for Frederick Douglas Freddie
and then Maya from my Angela these are
his wife has named the dog are the dogs
that are named after Frederick and Maya
what color one is white and one is black
and white Fred is black and white and
then Maya is all white oh really
see doesn't that seem a little listen it
all seems a little like it's a problem
don't name your dogs but my dad text me
the election night on the night of the
election my dad texts me he did it and I
was just like don't do you mean don't
you mean we did it doesn't mean we I
think that what do you mean by he did it
I got the text and I was just like yes
he did it was just funny and I was like
oh that doesn't seem like he you know
his wife was like very upset and went to
bed early and he was just kind of
he's like oh it doesn't seem cuz it
doesn't seem like you're broken up about
what and all everybody around us started
crying it kind of got like you like look
around yeah it's pretty [__] funny
funny it was funny that I was also just
like a lot of this is his show folks all
jokes a lot of it's a show
Obama had the camp's he had the people
in the camps I mean he wasn't dividing
the families but like it was a similar
situation it wasn't out of no it wasn't
one guy that can't deviate like listen
Trump I think the thing with Trump is
the aesthetic the way he talks the way
he deals with people that I how good was
that Baghdady speech though I mean he's
great
way better presidential speeches of all
he's made comedy almost irrelevant
comedy almost doesn't make any sense now
because you're never gonna be funnier
than him he's the funniest guy well I
mean his speech about ben Carson is
still the funniest thing I've ever seen
he went after his mother with a hammer
and he's like he's like he's like and he
tried to hit his friend with a lock and
he's talking about these revelations in
Ben Carson's book he's an eye or
something and he's just going and going
and it is so wild that you're like
spellbound you're like this is [__]
hilarious and he's just you know that
that we were jazz kind of talking though
we just you know have you seen his hour
right now that strong sour strong I've
been what you can YouTube any one of his
live events dude I've always drawn out
go to a rally and not because I'm like
agree with what he says and not because
the people there aren't [__] insane
anyone in any political rallies mentally
ill yeah right yes of all the things you
could do at your time to stand in a
[__] warehouse and here at narcissist
shout at you a sec although when I go on
tour I would like you to do that for me
but at least but I want to go to rally
cuz I think it is like the funniest show
that you'll ever see
oh the but I've I've fully accepted it
America's over and the we're like it's
done we're on the decline I'm like no
you don't think so now what what what
yeah college football still [__]
rules
so yeah that's a good we got going for
ya it's a cup you been to a game lately
no I should you should go to that oh
yeah I can get some I just think the
problems are too deep that if they do
get solved it'll be some miracle and
it's like I've I'm not personally
invested in like what it is what's gonna
happen gonna happen
we got a lot of you know we got amazin
comin a I the the reason the truck like
Trump is like I want Logan Paul because
here's the thing I like Logan Paul I met
Logan pulled in a seal Vaughn's podcast
do you remember Logan Paul with the
whole thing in the suicide forest loved
it yeah well I realize why people get
that angry at him but he you know he was
that like cancelled he was you know lost
endorsements he was being you know
attacked everybody online celebrities
people that were his friends and I
talked to him about that he goes people
I knew that where my friends were
turning on me and he goes I know I made
a mistake and I did a stupid thing
but he goes the vitriol hatred that was
coming at me from people that I was
friendly with and that I knew was wild
well it's also with that one it's also
like people like me I had never watched
any of his stuff until I watched that
episode where he was in Japan yeah
dressed as a Pokemon throwing pokeballs
at random Asian people right yeah then
when you're watching that you like Jesus
Christ yeah it's a little much he fully
admits that he was violent there's a
little while it was one this is why I
want him to be present I went to his
house to do a podcast he lives like the
kid from blank check he's just got
sneakers and Ferraris strewn around the
yard you know they've got a film crew
filming him him and his brother just
walk around he's like it's like Netflix
you know it it's terrifying and he said
to me he said to me and I he said the
music you know what in in ten years if
I'm bored I will run for president and I
had this really dark thought not only
would he do it but that he might win and
then I had even the darker thought I
went and he might not be that bad he
actually might be pretty good at it
and should I get involved now
to start trying to groom him if to be
the price should I be Logan Paul Steve
Bannon yes yes speak and here's why I'm
able to do it I've given up on the idea
that it's all gonna be okay like I think
I've embraced what the stage of the
empire were in and I think Logan Paul is
a fitting present for that stage of the
Empire Nero I think he's a fitting Nero
and I want to help him get there because
he had a horse and saying this is a
highly disciplined guy he's high fans
yes yes no I mean he's well put together
ABS I think I think he could do it
here's the other thing I think you have
all these youtube stars they're all in
in in in 15 years 20 years they're all
gonna be multimillionaires have huge fan
bases and no skills so I think that's
where that's the pool of people that
you're gonna get your politicians from
they're gonna come from YouTube because
that's you know they just they're only
provable skills like amassing these
large following hey guys
made a lot of minds their skill hey guys
hey guys just garbage but that's what
that's what's gonna win the presidency
soon hey guys are you feeling good like
I think things are gonna get so bad
we're like these guys are just gonna be
up like because I think the fireside
chat will be like a YouTube where they
just get on and go hey guys you feeling
good today I was feeling bad yesterday
but today I'm feeling a little better as
a makeup tutorial and I hope you are too
I think that's where we're going and
then they're gonna be like now watch me
eat the cereal very slowly you know it's
it's so I that's why I'm actually trying
to investigate what I would have to do
to - I think you're doing the right
thing right now getting in front of this
thing
let him know I'm letting him know who
you think of her voice
well no Paul Paul ticket
Paul Paul I don't know I I think we
we're gonna gotta go with a woman we got
to bounce out to straight whiteness of
it all you get whoa Vicki we need one of
them
yeah well Vicki you're bad baby we need
one of that baby baby
just got smacked up yeah someone knows
wove icky filly I think sounds feel they
both look like Kensington to me North
Philly where can you look up Bobby we're
bad babies from please and start
producing this goddamn show and wove ik
can we get out bed baby and we'll Viki
where they're from Thank You Bobby
I know when Rogen's in here everybody
pays attention when I come in everybody
likes to go to sleep they look like
either Long Island or Philly it does
yeah well they're their city where the
opioid crisis is yeah it's ravaged Ravan
Ravan area what do we got Bobby what do
we got Robert Robert Hutchins bad bad
babies from Florida yeah do it that's it
that'll do it
and what about whoa Vicki I think she's
from the desert now big baby has some
catchy songs what about Wolvie now
little Zen follows me on Twitter you
know the lizanne yeah little Zen yeah
yeah yeah I'm very happy now Sam's a
decent candidate I Janice you're
absolutely right about there's gonna be
a good cabinet it's gonna be good I
think the Chinese are there's no part of
me that's kidding about this I want
everyone to know that there's no part of
me that's kidding about trying to put
Logan Paul in the White House that's a
good ticket i I don't think he'd be that
bad where is well Vicky from Robert
she's from Atlanta Georgia
whoa Vicki if she good is well Vicki
yeah that's good that's what you want
for those red states you want to get a
someone from Georgia you need somebody
from Georgia in there that's good
Logan Paul I wove Ikki I think Logan
would be and are there any of those
YouTube guys because there's a lizard in
LA man you know there's no real line
between them and us there I mean
obviously the line of like he lives in a
mansion and I live in someone else's
house that they've abandoned um what is
the like he's ready YouTube guys are you
watching like oh that guy's funny uh
it's not our Sensibility yeah I don't
really watch too many I watched some
[__] vine some of those guys are good
yeah those vine story some of them are
tic TOCs hilarious well tic TOCs crazy
tick tock tick tock is every every clip
like if you go to a tick tock cringe
compilation yeah there's a person you've
never imagined every scene right it's a
face you've never seen right or a
thought that could exist that every
person is that ugly do you think that we
should be on tick-tock because I'm like
I wasn't on Twitter early I wasn't on it
I wasn't I'll never I don't think I'll
ever be on any of that stuff interesting
well you've had an experience with it it
was not a great time on to and I was
just getting on Twitter I like was just
figuring you know just try to use it you
just figured 2019 I slowly figured out
how to tweet things yeah and then once I
started that the wheels started turning
I got your first tweet was like hello
everybody
who retweeted the SNL sorry that was
your second tweet was like ladies and
gentlemen the fact that I did have a
relationship with Miss Lewinsky that was
wrong yeah that was that was a funny
part was having to write like these like
congressional apology yeah well talking
to Logan I talked to him about it he was
a gay goes you you really can't let that
[__] get in your head cuz it is a big
thing when people just come for you yeah
it's embarrassing afterwards yeah
afterwards when you realize how serious
you took it right and I kept trying to
remember that I was like just remember
in like a month you're gonna be like I
wish I didn't say all that that's
embarrassing yeah but I think I did I'm
proud of not proud but I'm okay with how
I did it yeah there's my first [__]
year in New York and that you know you
made a splash bride here your first year
in New York you made a big splash what
are you gonna do next year go on the
view shame killers get hired by the view
how great would that be that was like
one of my favorite uh there was this
there's there's a knock off view there's
like a urban view the talk the talk yeah
there's a big black lady somebody on
reddit referred to as mother nature
which really made me laugh mother nature
defends Django's
with that lady talking and one of the
sisters sisters tiara er Tamara one of
them that's on the show so the black
lady was like why boys be same like
[__] up things on purpose like they
know what's wrong so they say it right
and the hominid yeah and she was
defending it she was like it's how white
guys are they say [__] up things and a
sister sister was like wait so they know
it's wrong and they say it anyway yeah
yeah yeah that's it it's like for sure
yes yeah that's why he said it yeah I
knew it was wrong
interesting and was funny to see a
revelation occur to this yeah they're
like oh [__]
maybe that's what comedy is saying stuff
you shouldn't say dumb stuff that's a
taboo it was just things you should say
like think of the think of what that
would be like I was not in my prime
right I was not promised you know what
I've seen a few special since hers I had
no idea how good her as well hers is not
that bad I gotta be honest with you dude
some of the ones that have come out
after that I mean you you're like God
give us a Nanette yeah there was a yeah
yeah recent one with a lady who made it
to head talk to some [__] on me a little
and I was delighted to watch her special
it was as Nana's Papa says watching a
dictators daughter give his special to
an audience with guns to their head yeah
I mean that's what it was yeah you know
that's absolutely what it was and you
know we don't know if that pot is coming
at me Yanni and Chris that was wild
yeah I think it's funny hilarious really
yeah I mean that's what yeah I mean it's
you know she didn't even see what she
was taping especially she seemed like
she just like rolled in and everyone was
like surprised it's your birthday party
were taping a special yeah yeah what did
she say about you do you remember I
don't I'm not certain we're talking
about the same person but I think we
have to be yeah I don't know I didn't
listen to it I didn't listen to it so it
might not have even been that bad okay
but I ran into her later the next day
and the first thing she said to me was
like have you have you gotten therapy
have you seen someone because maybe
we're not talking about the same person
definitely not
and I feel bad what who are you talking
about ah probably didn't name okay yeah
there's no point there's no point Ania
cuz she might she might be great I don't
know her right and I don't even know
exactly what she said so can we play
meki leapers yeah let's just watch this
[__] let's play meki leapers meki
Libre is a friend of ours let's play go
to his Inn
two grand Bobby's Mickey leap we're
gonna play his video today he made a
video today in Times Square and very
proud of it he thinks it's really what
and like sometimes I'm like he's a smart
guy very smart very talented but
sometimes he does think that I'm like
this is goofy what are you doing here it
is turn it with the music up ba because
I mean look at that
what is this put the music on please
Bobby
is there a way to put the music on this
is what I love about cast is you I mean
he's spinning around and then he gets
grabbed by what Iron Man it's insanely
bad yeah it's so insane somebody goes
laughing my ass off this is like Glee
2007 well yeah you get so that's the
thing like yeah the mechs texture he's
got those glasses of [__] he's gonna get
those types of fans he's gonna get
people being like oh man this is good
reminds me of Glee Oh
now meanwhile you Amir getting fans are
like yeah you should say those words
please I'm getting fans with they're
like I'm armed and I'm ready wait for
whatever do I get dm's everyday bag hey
you want to come down and shoot you
wanna shoot some guns with Misha Stan
let's get [__] up and shoot it you me
and my dad are gonna go shoot guns it's
not sweet it's like thanks man wear it
now where can it's interesting to ask
you for plugs where can people find you
I mean let's plug the pod cuz yeah yeah
Matt and Shane's secret podcast Matt
Shan secret pocket change
that's secret it's not that secret
anymore you've had it been secret this
guy would be I'll be doing alright
you'd be on Weekend Update right now
yeah I would have got fired
you think I think eventually I would get
fired interesting pretty I mean yeah if
ya live dates plugs odd what do we add
uh when's this getting released coming
out Sunday okay alright so
all next week I'm in the city the next
thing I have is just November 30th
laughing up a Kip see December 13th and
14th Worcester Mass at wha 26 27 28 to
December Magoo bees and I just added
today I just added helium Buffalo and
then stress factory in New Jersey both
stress factories comics for money and I
don't know just [__] go listen to
Matt and change secret pocket and your
website have a website with your dates
yeah and I gotta fix it cuz it sucks
Shane M Gilles dog okay actually I'm
Gilles on Twitter I'll post ego hyenas
Fort Worth folks this weekend November
14 to the 16 coming up
Vermont comedy club November 21st
through the 23rd stress factory in
Bridgeport Connecticut December 5th
through the 7th comedy connection
Providence Rhode Island 13th and 14th
Mugu B's January 9 to 11
zany Chicago Illinois February 5th
through the 8th house at comedy
Bloomington Minnesota Minneapolis
Bloomington in the Bloomington MN
Bloomington Minneapolis April 9th
through the 11th house accomodate
Phoenix Arizona May 7th through the 9th
comic strip Edmonton June 18 to 20 the
Caroline's first weekend headlining
Caroline's in New York awesome yeah
March 12th through the 14th pretty wild
very exciting yeah should be fun
so grab some of those tickets too if you
can Tim Jay Dylan VI ll win on Instagram
and Twitter and go follow Shane go leave
the show you know 5 star rating and a
review tell your friends about it share
those videos that we make you know
unless they'll get you fired we don't
want that I don't need that out of my
[__] head and or you know what you
know take a stand and get fired and
share the video yeah don't apologize go
home and don't apologize you know tell
you tell your family listen we got we
got a we got a [__] we got to just
[__] take one for the team here and
we're not gonna know we're not gonna be
able to live
we're not gonna be able to live but then
show them and yeah it'll be very fun
than the video you know Lauren thank you
folks goodbye hey guys it's been the
producer of the show I'm recording alone
in LA right now Tim is still in New York
I'm not sure what he's up to is probably
at Smith & Wollensky 'he's taken
pictures of meat or he's turning
Epstein's townhouse into an influencer
wall I don't know what he's up to
so I'm just sort of laying around
thinking of different ways to destroy
Tim's career if you listen to the show
you know that's pretty much my main role
is I'm constantly trying to sabotage
everything tim has built over the past
decade I devised a great idea to take
Tim down and that is I'm going to post a
30-minute teaser for the patreon episode
this week at the end of this episode so
that's what you're about to hear is Tim
and rake hump in a hotel in New York
just a 30-minute teaser
I'm incentivizing you guys to go sign up
for the patreon patreon.com slash the
ten villains show here's the thing
there's a hundred and forty five
archived episodes and a bonus episode we
do every week that's a lot of content to
sift through you could probably find
something in there that's very foul or
problematic and you could take down Tim
he's on the verge of becoming a very big
comedian I can't have that happening so
we need to take him down
there's conspiracy theory episodes
there's Whitney Webb former CIA agents
Nick Bryant russ Baker there's a great
episode where Tim interviews someone who
almost got killed by a gang of serial
killers called the smiley face killers
there's a lot of funny episodes too
there's an episode where me and Tim were
just driving around Beverly Hills and he
has the window rolled down and he's just
screaming about you know pedophiles and
billionaires and dark money episodes
with Yanis Papa's Raycom there's a great
episode with Jessa read where she talks
about talking to aliens and tapping into
a higher dimension there's a whole
assortment of stuff not to mention we
post longer versions of the sketches
there and other video content 10 post
pictures he posts updates there's about
1500 people that are that have already
joined the patreon so please go over and
join that and help me finally take Tim
down
so here now is a 30 minute teaser from
the episode Tim did with the great
Raymond comp from a hotel in New York
this week where Tim considers running
for president but yeah I mean I don't
know man I I do think that youtubers are
you know as annoying as many of them are
right you know they figured something
out
should I get on YouTube when I walk
around yes no yes bordered by gimmick be
shy be like a chef or so I think you'd
have to go pay pig hey peg there's no
legitimate pay pigs or pigs you're like
find on like financial domination where
you call somebody a doctor for your
money but that's not that's like hot
chicks do that what I think you should
do is like mukbangs where people feed
you oh you'd have to like eat a whole
you could get on and like eat a whole
Boston Market chicken and collect the
sounds you know and then describe it did
you get 200,000 views if I'm up bang if
you went and recorded yourself eating a
Boston Market chicken with the gravy and
just slurping animal baby the bones I
don't know if you'd eat the bones but I
think you would get you could I'm not
even kidding you might get a quarter
million views or more I like watching
could go viral if you started thinking
like that I like watching those videos
where those guys go to Taco Bell and eat
the whole menu or like trapeze it so
there's something comforting about like
a guy goes out of guard and then he eats
like everything on the menu and it's
just like we're always weird variations
he's just like in getting sick he hates
it he's feeling like you know he's
slurring getting slow that true yeah I
mean the whole thing he's eating like a
bite of each like like weaves eating you
know chicken carbonara checking
carbonara bacon now chicken carbonara
with like a bite or two for an hour two
hours you need tired me out menu of
Olive Garden yeah I didn't even know
that was on rrah
it's called it's a try guys oh and they
just eat the whole restaurant the only
thing they do I guess best of all i
watch with them he goes to McDonald or
any Burger King his Arby's did know why
he's so harsh on YouTube a lot nice
enjoy Alex Jones yeah what happened to
him he
he didn't really eat a lot he was
talking about coffee occasionally but
yeah I think if you went into that
situation anywhere you started like you
know you had a channel might be a
competitive eater right because that
guy's like stone Alex really like I'm
literally like a hundred Big Macs if you
like one on YouTube put like like beat
like ground chuck beef you hook it you'd
cook it right like you put in your mouth
and just squish it and ate it and then
poured milk over your head you would get
like hundreds of thousands of years
why am I not doing it because here's
what people don't realize technology is
that Pandora's Box it's been open you
can't put it back in and it's really
making people sick yeah like all the
things that just crossed your head where
you would just be like all right that
that's not right I'll just get rid of
that like we're really going into this
very strange weird rabbit hole like
things we just want to see yeah would
you want to watch things right we're all
becoming weird passive viewers and we
just want to watch things you need to
get a hobby I keep saying it but like
you know people need to do have hobbies
just watch the truck that's not hobby a
passive things aren't hobbies I'll build
a Mylo car okay that should be the
Biggest Loser hobby ever stamp
collecting tennis what about tennis
that's a hobby sure yeah why do you have
to be stamped like why does it have to
be some weird cereal maybe a [__]
hobby it collected people's skin got
something you could really sink your
teeth from just a hobby stamp collect
these as big as it used to be but the
guy who I used to live in his house and
he died why did he thought you
confessing to something I got to confess
here's an old man oh yeah you stamp
collection he was also the head of the
prisons of a psychiatric prison in
Suffolk County for a while had at the
time how did you meet him I was just
Craigslist
they vouch for you who did know I mean
like I thought you got him through the
prison no he was a head of psychiatric
you just met him through Craigslist yeah
and you told him you worked at the jail
did he like that the morgue
like that yeah that was contagious I
used to be like you barely talking and
Stroke already that bright and sometimes
I was here midnight going ice water I
saw that because like his son is this
drug addict drug recovering we quote his
summers in recovery yeah a voice box
like now this good guy his son had no
voice we have the voice box yeah how
about that thing all I want to talk like
this yeah hello why did he have a voice
was it lung cancer lung cancer
I mean his son had a voice box yeah he
told me when I first came in like my son
yeah he's a survivor
am i great perfect he's good guys his
son but I guess even getting no way I
think the dad was a little abusive when
they were growing up because he would
not go get him ice water even though he
was asking really eventually maybe I
know one time he fell in the bathroom
and my friend was over in my friend's a
little drunk and he was like I would
this point low desensitized to like he's
always making noises and like the sun's
gonna come down like when we're gonna
storm into their house like I'm in the
basement it'd be like I don't have free
reign as he's yelling help help what are
you and your drunk friend doing oh I'm
fine we have to help that man and he's
probably fine back down eventually my
friend wouldn't shut bad so I called
Robert I said I think your father is uh
is fallen yeah eventually like oh I'll
take a look at it and yeah the next day
he's like thanks for calling me because
he was you know he's fallen in the
bathroom and he was stuck between the
toilet and the bathtub I think
collectors my point we need a war with
China we need a war with China kids
Mabel get your ice water within four
years I mean I man God thank God we will
not be nine-day yeah I was at this
wedding recently and I was like I think
I want to get married and have more of a
traditional life yeah me too yeah why
don't we get
have a joint like I'm not marrying you
we'll have a joint wedding together
that's an interesting idea
yeah I'll marry Lucy and you can marry
you know Logan Paul whoever yeah welcome
Paul man I'm telling you the marriage
convenience for him he's gonna do a lot
better than you think I will back him
for president
I need a nose watch the Steve ban and
doctor the night Mike I need a trump you
need I need a trump you think you think
you have a tactical mine for that kind
of thing well I mean if not who cares
sure but you just want you um you wanna
be king maker I mean yeah I thought you
were the star you need a bad it I'd like
to play a little game there but I'm
talking about years from now and I'm
bored of comedy and I don't give a [__]
right you you need to be Trump not you
don't need to find you know you need to
find a baton it's an interesting
question should I be the president
FairPoint right I'd take you over
[__] I don't think a book and Paul's
gonna connect with the masses he's
taking with kids but like the people who
like he's knocking about with people to
our frenzy look you can you can you know
you can get these interesting now you're
making me think maybe the president the
United States shouldn't be Logan Paul
should be me yeah I agree
Wow it's very interesting I don't know
I'll be your goddamn Steve Madden yeah I
mean maybe I mean this is an interesting
question you know first thing you do is
you gotta get fatter you know you're not
weird in between you need to be a chris
Christie type they want real fat yeah
yeah political cartoons yeah you either
move that you use it move move your
permanent residence you have to live
there but you have to be a resident of
Pittsburgh I like that yeah first of all
I don't hate these ideas right and I
have no here's the thing I have a
nickname yeah now what is the nickname
uh-oh uh-oh its trouble stick name what
you mean like the Donald like you don't
know there was the Donald there was I'm
trying to think oh they call him my they
call him the god Emperor whoever got
input all right everybody online they
comb the goddamn so you you are you
asking me for what the all rights gonna
call you online or us you were a
nickname I need an elf juego el fuego
what do you that mean the flame of the
fire not because you're gay because this
is like this in general I don't know if
I could pull out
that sounds very Latin it is what about
the boss no the chunk chunk shock
what about come chunk they come chunk
come chunk come child
why not just like so young [__] Pig what
are you doing why not slow yeah look you
can call you someone yeah call yourself
the pig the pig yeah dad I like the pig
go get it pig pigs comfortable in the
mud piggle do what it wants yeah and pig
tastes real good smarter than me look
pig is smarter than he looks at pigs
sometimes it makes a sacrifice it feeds
all family yeah a pig can do it yeah a
pig will do it I'm a hard-working pig
I'm your Pig I'm now your Pig America
speech thank you as crazy as Trump
coming down the thing you literally get
naked you get in the nude you get into
the mud it was with locks picks yeah
like with pigs you know this is what I
am now I'm here for you I am your Pig
yeah and you're just like you know
there's a blur you out to show you and
look at these animals these animals a
date they're perfectly adapted for their
environment yeah
they roll around in the mud they love it
they enjoy it you're not like humping
the pig we've probably mounting it just
right sake of it projection of power
yeah the pig
Tim Dylan the pig is here yeah I'm your
Pig America I'm just sitting there
watching with clipboards you know like
you know Tim Dylan American Pig they're
American Pig American Pig this could win
this could [__] is I'm not even
kidding this is not the worst idea
are we doing 2020 or waiting for the
point we're wait and we wait we we've
missed the boat on 20 but we're doing
2024 American Pig yeah he's from
Pittsburgh right what are they famous
for its not Philly cheesesteaks what are
they um yeah
but loose meat sandwich I think yeah
that's what they're yeah clastic people
oh you've your simple people you salt of
the earth just want a nice cold beer and
I'm sandwich the loose meat
watch the Steelers you need a pig to do
your bidding in Washington yeah
I will be that pig right interesting the
Pittsburgh pig and you will you call out
a fellow congressmen whatever yeah it's
my god I say to you right that's what my
supporters will do guys will be pig
noses this is so much less tasteful the
Joker like Joker one this is like the
most tasteless villain we just had that
bacon at the rallies I feel like we
could make this work I mean now I'm
really thinking maybe I was wrong about
Logan Paul maybe I should just do Logan
Paul can be like Treasury who are some
right good idea making like national
security advisories liens yeah he's buff
exactly I need to really run the show
yeah use the cabinet we'll have Logan
Paul you find me a job
yeah economics Treasury thank you yeah
Treasury or chairman of the Fed or
something we're gonna stop defense here
we give her defense because that's just
even to her oh yeah okay for Rogen's got
to do something
Rogan can be National Security Advisor
very highly disciplined guy yeah I'm
thinking Secretary of State he's very
good at talking to people yeah I think
we're a science II kind of thing Oh
interesting but what is that even uh I
mean the thing is like the I record the
agriculture secretary like an insult
state state state okay we can get Andrew
yang to run the private prisons okay I
think he'd be good at that I like that
Burnie can Bernie's dead by the time so
we've killed he's gonna die naturally
can we get Hillary be your running mate
now she's gonna she goes I said bye dude
do you think she's getting back in why
is she all over the news right now
what's she been doing the news I heard
it was a little bit about this but
what's going on The Daily Show she's on
the view she's kind of making around
she's doing the late night show she'll
call Bear she's out there do you think
she's gonna go last-minute swoop in to
the primary I don't know what she's
gonna do but Fox News you cheetah Paul
what she beats Trump she beats Trump
yeah
Fox News oh the Fox News completely
turned on Trump it's now they've
definitely shifted a bit um I don't know
I don't know I don't really watch them
frequently no I hated them in the
beginning and then they got off they got
on board very late Fox News aired the
organ of establishment Republican
opinion sure but they're also like you
know pig slop yeah but only when they
realized it was too much slop that they
had to get in the mud they weren't they
were gonna back Josh well there's five
News use Rush Limbaugh's all against
Trump Hannity the whole crew really the
only person was with him was Ann Coulter
okay everybody know I know they weren't
like back in him as a de facto candidate
but like I don't feel like Fox Fox News
isn't like Charles Krauthammer and
[__] you know like it was on fire he
was no he's also like you know I'm
spoken my point is he was a white
Republican establishment and Trump I
mean Fox wasn't really like that no a
very mainstream Country Club
conservative establishment it'll also
did not like Trump in the beginning okay
they prisoner were they love him by mean
like you by the country club Republicans
didn't watch funny saying what are you
talking about of course they did you're
talking about this a fetal intellectual
Bill Kristol wing National Review right
that is very small heritage you know
think-tank guys yeah you're right that's
not the rank-and-file right you know
even though the other guys like they
make three grand a year they they did
the dummies know you of course wanted to
came in right you want to go home in
here boo you know Laura Ingraham defend
the use of the n-word yeah sure
lots of nice entertainment but uh Oh
Clinton yeah I don't see beating is she
getting a nomination is she beaten war
and even no but but but I don't know I
mean here's the bigger question the one
thing this whole impeachment Biden wins
usually buys you the win listen listen
to me
Biden whips he picks Hillary's his VP
yeah they win Biden's so dirty with this
Ukraine [__] right he gets impeached
Hillary's the president house of cards
sure that means gonna be fun do you
think do you think is Ukraine thing
hurts Biden like that's like like
severely I think I don't know I think
that that obviously I'm just flattering
and floating a conspiracy theory that's
fun
no of course but he is dirty it could
wound him he's like he's deadly and
mortally I don't know I mean III think
Trump's dirtier but I you thinking
whatever doubt you know what about you
see you don't think he'll dogs getting
back in I'm not saying he is I'm just
trying to think of like why she would
wait interesting I just think that there
is no clear
[Music]
we my point is do you think she's seeing
a field going it no one's really God I
think she is yeah I think there's a
potential that she's looking at the
field going nobody's got it
nobody is a plurality of support right
the left and the right is to the flanks
or between Warren and Bernie and Biden
and buddhic Chege are the divides are
pretty deep yeah you know the Medicare
for all socialists and you know Blue Dog
Democrat corporatists whatever you want
to call them right and I think Hillary
might want to just come out and be like
listen I'm the first one to bring up
Medicare for all I'm the first one to
try to do it years ago in the 90s yeah I
made a mess but I was you know and I'm
also a warmonger and I love but yes I
put my email a private server why they
do that I got fingers in pies yes they
just said that
dude if she was like Trump she might
have won like yeah it's like listen who
gives a [__] the people died were you
pretty little head about it people close
to me died everyone is someone close to
them it dies
hey Jake Tapper don't worry your pretty
little head about where my emails go I'm
not saying I killed Vernon Jordan but he
was a rat we were in Jordan's alive boom
I dig it up oh that guy's shot of it
twice in the head Vince Foster she's
like nobody cries for Vince Foster you
think he was a hero you think Vince
Foster was a hero I don't know man it'd
be interesting to see her get back in
yeah I mean she lost one
[Music]
she won the popular vote oh yeah by
millions here he'll win again now if she
runs probably I don't know I mean
FoxNews ever been wrong she has to if
she runs again she has to be to the
right and to the left of him yeah like
she has to say that we're gonna kill
people who come across the border we'll
kill him kill we're gonna put them in
camps they are gonna be concentration
camps yeah and medicare-for-all and
guaranteed to your unemployment I'm
building the wall in China yes she goes
we're gonna we're gonna turn those you
know those camps on the border we're
gonna turn them into concentration it's
not just gonna be a slogan anymore it's
gonna be an actual camp not [__]
around here yeah it's a brutal sport
this bloody you think it'd be better
with Hillary do I think the country were
doing better with Hillary I mean listen
we always talked about this the majority
of things wouldn't be that different
right she'd be you know maybe lobbing a
few more missiles in Assyria people yeah
Syria would you know we've had maybe
similar right she wouldn't be doing he's
drupe economy's done well with that yeah
I mean Hillary really doing anything to
hurt stocks though oh why were those our
family Congress I mean Wall Street I
mean sorry is pretty dumb a lot of the
time yeah I mean there's some guys were
smarter than me they're gonna be wrong
but some some but the point is like Oh
Trump's enough now with stockbrokers
blooming like what do you think Hillary
was gonna do now yeah yeah it's like
giving speeches to this baby yeah but
I'll tell you this it would be do I feel
like I said it's Rogan I was like we're
I feel like we're on the edge of it
feels like that scene in the movie were
like you know a car is hanging off the
edge of a cliff and just it's not
falling nothing's happening right we've
been living at that moment for the last
since Trump got elected and a lot of
it's the media but a lot of issues of
him as well well and it's such an
unhealthy place to be in that second
with no like resolution to anything it
just feels like raw
suspended in midair waiting for some
here's why ban is either a [__] or a
liar because he kept saying how we're we
don't change something revolutions gonna
happen yeah
who is gonna fight it yeah [__] whale
a bad we're not doing anything knows
full well yeah revolutions that happen
but Bannon also knows the idea of it is
what keeps you know my point is I think
because like a low-level white
nationalist terrorism oh sure but my
point is a larger point oh we feel like
we're gonna break us something I mean we
all realize that like we're not going to
brink of anything we're like we're that
brink of realizing that like there's
nothing we can do to change it and like
this high status quo and like as a putin
de who nothing more is that different
strategy it's more like yeah you know
I'm [__] you I know you know I'm
[__] it that's what we're doing and
like it's just kind of accepted that's
also the way that they've been for a
very long time sure this country
operates in in in Isola thatthose you
know the entertainment industry and the
media and like right you know
myth-making and storytelling and we're
very good at that and I think that the
younger generation maybe they are more
active maybe they will push things in
the right direction I don't know we
needed the new fast-food thing should I
date David hog yeah yeah I think I
should start dating him yeah he's gay
right no I don't think he has a
sexuality it's a very odd mouth was like
a mealy-mouthed yeah strange movies to
do some I don't know hello who's this oh
hi David this is Tim Dylan how are you
oh I've seen you on live at Gotham David
David I was about that I was at a show
called Gotham access comedy live on
access TV
I was great you're really mad Popeye so
how are you I was he was a good bit
thank you David how are you doing have
you been ok I know that a lot of people
are angry you know I was in the school
shooting yes and David I'm sorry
thank you I'm sorry about that and I
also think it should be harder for
people to get cuts you wanna make love
David when he's your last I'm supposed
to be seduced you
getting you getting out of control I
feel like this isn't you it I feel like
this is somebody I wanna mom I mean
what's a guy like that do for fun what's
a guy like David Hogg do for fun I mean
I feel like he wouldn't be funny if I go
shooting yeah I feel like he's got a gun
I feel like you think so
I absolutely believe what if he can only
comment I put a gun to his head David
yeah he's like you know as much of an
activist as I am I can actually only
come if Tim puts a gun to my head he's
an interesting this terrorism I don't
know sometimes I send this to ban and he
goes it was so funny that has to be the
regular episode not the patreon episode
so we never really we never really know
where it goes usually for patreon people
get that we're kidding around and the
thing's a joke and that everybody is a
joke and that all we all we care about
you know all the children of the world
and you know the climate and the people
and all the goodness should think yeah
that's see maybe that'll be the thing
that really invalidates like the climate
might just start kicking our asses in a
way that like politics seems like the
good old days when we like 20 years from
now it really gets bad I mean it's
saying that Manhattan's underwater in 20
that's true people are you basing your
thing on the way people talk our papers
are they just Rosa listen me and Ben had
this me and Ben we may film this sketch
ready um you know this one Bobby short I
happen to like New York I'm no no play
it get it because we want to film this
sketch with you we want to rent out the
Carlisle this is gonna cost you much
money and have you I'll be short yeah I
happen to love New York you're in a suit
it's a very small jazz band in cafe
Carlyle and you sing this song
and the families and the children are
smiling and swag yes and everybody's mad
it is magical in the Carlisle and you're
just singing it and you just look great
you're in a big suit I won for Battery
Park that that that thing that flashed
we're sitting in Penn Station the way
they surrounded by like homeless people
and addicts people vomiting and then
there was just as on the TV those dishes
flash because take it encapsulated this
whole show and everything that we had
thought like in just that one image with
like this girl just vomiting all people
crawling on the floor yeah heroin
addicts scratching themselves crack
heads and then it just said hey take the
liberty Christmas thank you're free you
know that you're free dummy it's gonna
be fun it's gonna be fun how long have
we done here 15 I like to go to Battery
Park I think that would be such a great
yeah you'll rent a tux so I you know
give me those microphones welcome to New
York I happen to like New York I happen
to like New Yo I like to go to Battery
Park I like to go to Battery Park and
then the whole the whole place is
swaying and all the kids are hot there's
just a magic to it there's a magic so
maybe you're in a big white ciouds
around Christmas not [__] I'm just
having them around cuz they're fine let
make you think about the future if you
didn't have to like your Kirby I happen
to like New York I like to eat brain at
this place in Queens
I added at a media conglomerate to
trailing I do enjoy an uber pool I had
my phone stolen by a high beach
I still love new I like to eat hot dogs
in the rain yeah you gotta come out to
Los Angeles a little bit sure you get a
guy you gotta get the vibe of it you
know that we're like supreme and you
know start skating you me I mean I could
I have a skate park right next to me my
okay I start skating and then we start
wearing supreme and become a high beast
I mean I don't think most Gators of
height B's are they I have a skate park
or skate park well I'm just saying I go
hang out there like you know no well I
think what you should do though is you
come to LA and you get the idea it's
nice and warm
yeah it feels nice it's on fire sure you
know we're gonna blame me for the fire
people should but people might you know
they absolutely could I mean I would
love to go out there I could probably
get a job out there and well I don't
know about that you trip get a job can
you get a job interesting interesting
what does Lucy feel about that well she
might look if she gets a writing job she
wants to really like she keeps trying it
right enjoy so if my aunt had balls
she'd be my uncle would that mean Lucy's
work for you no I'm not saying that Lou
she's not gonna get a writing job I'm
saying there's too many ifs what do you
say well I mean if we have a week we
shall have a writing job here no so then
so then so then what's the you know a
that's like if that happened we
immediately move okay
I'm saying we talked about going that
way okay all right
who knows who knows can all get writing
job I'm just saying it might be
interesting to take a little vacation I
would love to yeah to see what it's
about
we might do it so you could stay with me
you know on the street in front of my
house sir you know you lose you can stay
right under stream and um
you could see the law the whole
operation out there what skid row well
yes I mean Skid Row's not even anything
I mean it's like it's pretty it's a POC
post-apocalyptic right but all of
downtown LA is really which no one goes
to downtown that sounds like the City of
LA like the city with the skyscrapers
dr.nader no one who's in those building
record companies rich people that have
big loft some artists come accompany
them like what kind of company let me
ask you this question what kind of
contact support huge okay
biggest biggest biggest import-export in
LA everything comes from China through
LA massive companies like that okay so
like commercial shipping yeah but
there's some rich people down there but
I think the majority of rich people live
in the hills in the DLA life is a
suburban life right so nobody wants that
city when you go downtown LA what is
know you know where I live in West
Hollywood that's the LA that people know
about or Beverly Hills or go down to the
beach like Santa Monica Venice
can you Airbnb Beverly Hills bigger than
you think
no I mean parts of it maybe but not not
what you're thinking about right I mean
yeah I mean there's probably there's a
houses there that you could rent for a
hundred grand a week or something new
you know yeah I mean there's some
there's some homes you can probably [__]
me it would probably be you'd have to
pay more you have to pay it would be 150
grand but no I would be you'll be in
Jersey to see what you're I think you
should come in January when it gets
froze sure no me I'll start saving up
for it you know I mean it's not that
expensive know what I'm saying I put
some money aside yeah for a ticket you
know because you've only you've never
flew coach I've never flown coach I know
it's like you you complain a lot about
coach yeah I've only flown first class
and Ray he's true he's only first class
man to and from New Orleans yeah one
yeah do talk about crab cakes on the way
there and I think some kind of peel off
from the way back interesting yeah
interesting and you and that is the only
flight you've been on yeah and it was
first class that is the way to do it I
mean wasn't that kind of the way to do
it well yeah it's not that long a flight
you think it'd be like leather recliners
just kind of like whatever yeah it's a
nice it's like a coach bus it's it was
eat what airline Delta yeah I mean a
little nicer in the coach bus but like
now it's just short flight what's New
Orleans three and a half two and a half
maybe two and a half three I want to go
back to those red city
when does he it's cold there now right
no no I went there in December and it
was like 70s
yeah that's bright you're right about
that yeah yeah yeah I gotta get down
ever gets cold really I mean that's a
good point it probably doesn't get that
call yeah god I missed that place
Brandon you know maybe Thursday Friday
I'll just ditch my spots and go there
yeah cuz it makes her sword oh it's the
best no excuse art is the best if you're
in New Orleans go to Brennan's get the
eggs whoo sword it says he's been
thinking like a wine sauce which in a
cup or wine really a red wine reduction
whatever yeah so good it's just so good
New Orleans and those hotels you can get
really nice hotel super cheap really
good really good really interesting yeah
man yeah maybe you have to be a guy from
New Orleans press go to Battery Park
yeah like mark Normand said me once he's
like I like my truest form is like a guy
sweating in a white suit in Commander's
Palace in New Orleans like hitting on
the waiter like make him very
unconfident
yeah he's like boy go and get me some
butter and I know what Buddha is don't
you